the new cost of a data breach report
financial services level controls with
ibm cloud satellite and a buy one get to
promo offer all on this episode of ibm
cloud now
what's up y'all my name is ian and i am
back to bring you the latest and
greatest news and announcements from ibm
cloud
as many of you may be aware october is
national cybersecurity awareness month
and to contribute our expertise towards
the movement ibm cloud has released a
new report called cost of a data breach
a view from the cloud the findings of
the report show that while there have
been fewer data breach incidents
reported this past year the impact and
severity of those breaches has worsened
luckily the results show a consistent
conclusion you can mitigate risk with a
more comprehensive end-to-end approach
to cloud security
as such the report offers four steps you
can take to build that more
comprehensive level of protection
one is to go hybrid
two is to reach a state of mature
migration
three is to use the right security and
four is to automate with artificial
intelligence
this quick summary only scratches the
surface so make sure you check out the
full cost of a data breach report which
i've got linked in the description of
this video
next up i'm excited to announce that ibm
cloud satellite now extends benchmark
financial services level controls into
any environment
this means you can get a consistent set
of security compliance and risk
management controls anywhere on other
clouds on premises or at the edge
these new controls will allow you to
apply industry leading keep your own key
encryption via ibm cloud hyper protect
services
you can also enable consistent security
audit event logging and compliance
monitoring with ibm cloud services which
facilitates workload portability and
controls data movement
to learn more about ibm cloud satellite
and these new features hit the link
below
to wrap things up this week let's take a
quick look at a new buy one get to promo
right now you can spin up a monthly ibm
cloud bare metal server with select
intel xeon processors and get two
additional months cost free
you've got two kind of processors to
choose from a flexible entry-level
configuration and a powerhouse that is
ideal for multiple heavy-duty workloads
this promotion is for new and existing
ibm cloud account holders who do not
currently have these servers running on
their account so check out the blog i've
linked below to get started with the buy
one get two promo
thanks so much for joining me today for
this episode of ibm cloud now if you're
interested in learning more about the
topics i've covered make sure you
explore the links in the description of
this video and again please don't forget
to subscribe to our channel to stay up
to date on what's going on in the cloud
now